yeah hello and welcome to this twitch
stream the Monday night live show is on
and I hope um got to get some some of us
soon yet I was takes a moment until yeah
people come in and I see some people in
the chat so um what am I going to do um
I'm going to play one tournament I was
thinking and my idea was to play this
one the how early super blitz and then
do some viewer challenges that was my
idea let's do it dropped frames detected
that's not good I hope that this is a
good quality stream let me know how it
turned how it turns out yeah I had a
couple of dropped frames
alexsei borisovitch yeah and this was
the other thing that I was thinking hey
I'm going to berserk a bit in this in
this tournament it's a bit tricky to do
against a relatively high rated opponent
let's see how this turns out not so
happy with this not so happy with this
position I think I played a somewhat
questionable autumn the main issue emma
is the Boozer King
so let's see what happens my authority
for could become a target 117 is not a
lot it really isn't
yeah and I know what to all of you in
the chat I'm happy to have a couple of
guys in there
so what goes on I like say Boris a witch
what is he doing yeah I'm happy that he
takes a bit of time this one hmm
yeah cannot really trade is the thing
yeah
24 is not threatening anything and this
is not a happy move either
he's got 95 yeah my d5 when the opening
wasn't a good idea really wasn't yeah
it's the stream quality okay I hope it
is okay maybe 94 even coming okay I'm
stopping a four and now try this okay
good quality this is good to hear
interesting
if five is not a move that I expected
I'm not sure if it is a good idea for
blank or not good 94 coming up this is
interesting
maybe this yeah this is a bit of an
issue that he's got it is first on the
open file
yep that will be a problem a bazooka is
okay I just I just need a better
position
I miss played the opening quite terribly
I think I could be okay again such a
player buzzer King but not with a with a
terrible opening I mean you see that
he's playing this rather badly rugby -
okay so we saw that one okay so let's
see how I can fear I'm still going to be
Zerg every game that was the idea make
it a bit more yeah I played oops
now I forgot to berserk oh great okay I
can so play quickly
I simply don't have it in the system all
that much yeah I screwed up the opening
and then he had an easy game okay that
looks comfortable now I really forgot to
berserk I forgot to click that after
John Cazale Museum okay John Ross dreamy
eyes I think it's - dreaming for Chester
- calm I guess yeah I couldn't really
bring myself
do that the playing platform is just so
bad I mean yeah I should have enough
there maybe that wasn't me there was a
quick decision I didn't really realize
I'm giving up the default pawn which she
does not take funny enough so I'm you
know I'm playing quickly I didn't bezerk
but I'm trying to play in the spirit of
buzzer King can't push this Auto buzzer
King
yeah it would be a good idea actually so
that you cannot forget it so and what's
going on here III doesn't help how do I
do that
Bishop to c7 it would also be pretty
cool huh unsure how to play this
position maybe - one supporting
everything preparing III as well I
shouldn't pre move anything would rather
see what he does no III is on the cards
I don't know I don't see how he prevents
it with their form maybe yeah what's up
is looking that's really good idea yeah
I don't see a good move for white III is
a terrible threat so instead of taking
any
thing I don't see I don't see it so I'm
pushing on the porn
yeah D 2 e 2 and so on oh it results
okay so next one and again now I have to
have to do it
yeah we've called John a streaming on
Twitch because it's a platform that he
has to stream on if he goes with the
chest on comedy but I think it's also
the better platform it simply has more
possibilities whoa
thanks for the top cheer so I've got my
good old chigorin main and main thing is
I can play many more squid quickly let's
see I'm basically playing bullet time
control yeah one thing that I wanted to
mention because it's something that I
did not know only learn that very very
recently on twitch you have this system
with subscriptions you can subscribe to
this channel or other channels and it
costs you $5.00 usually and this these
five dollars a month they are for the
streamer not totally twitch things
Howard but I would get half of that so
you would support me streaming if you
subscribe so this was clear to me but
what I did not know is that if you have
an Amazon Prime membership and many
people have that yeah having this prime
service booked from Amazon if you have
that you actually have one from your
subscription for a twitch channel and
you can choose what the channel that may
be so if you don't have any subscription
yet to any channel but you have a twitch
you have an Amazon Prime membership you
can consider simply to take this free
subscription and subscribe to my channel
it costs you absolutely nothing so so
yeah I'm getting the ax from now and
yeah I'm quite happier you for porn is
good to get and after getting a form I
[Music]
followed the lead thank you yes I really
do that that that subscription by using
the the Amazon Prime account Amazon is
basically paying the the five the five
bucks and it cost you absolutely nothing
yeah this is a fork and the rook cannot
cover this yeah
give me the points please lipid Samia
okay that's actually a good idea let's
do let's take this take this and then
push the C pawn I don't think he can
stop it probably go for a one yeah he's
still hanging on
yeah correct and it's actually a bit of
the work now I should have taken the
friggin rook I did swindle himself out
of this crap I mean at least it wasn't a
completely quick win made next okay so
let's see I'm getting closer
yeah sings thanks for subscribing with
twitch privately yeah I think this is a
good thing a good thing that they that
they have that I mean so Ludo man should
do this let's go here is that good for
me it looks fine right can that be bad
probably not yes after this tournament
I'm going to play some viewers
[Music]
it seems white is somehow not willing to
take this pawn okay I could cost him and
now I'm ever I have a deadly pin I
believe I can move the knight simply
right there's no big point-down still
pinned
so John pathology was streaming right
before me what did he do play viewers or
what was the main content of the show
and have you watched
okay that's just 960 okay I'm not sure
in case of this there's a question here
if she rose bishop age three in this
famous game was the only winning move
I'm not sure really I mean I obviously
looked at this game at some point but I
don't remember that looks funny here
after this he has no moves anymore the
rooks cannot move f4 you cannot play
that looks very funny here I'm just
walking the king of âge three ya cows
and a camera have a chance 960 match
coming up in Norway that's true that
certainly will be interesting to watch
with chess960 eights I'm always a little
bit undecided because there are certain
things that I like about it but it's
also quite often an incredibly
understating kind of chess iam just like
we had piece placement and so on I like
to watch it being played and explained
to me it's somehow interesting but
sometimes when I play that myself I kind
of feel everything is wrong and it takes
time to sort of get get to something
that looks like chess vaguely funny
so tank box is actually pretty high
rated
still I don't think this is I mean I
don't feel yeah I could do it assignment
of leeches that's certainly an option
maybe maybe d5 was the easier easier
move to play him just to have easier
easier moves in the future
I mean I like this position I'm a little
bit better but it'll be no any things
are a little bit easier for me to play
this is of course a fine a fine position
but considering that observed you have
to worry about playing quickly okay put
a bit more time here what would be nice
indeed yeah but should be to wear over
loop this that could be a problem now
I'm not going to play horde chess I'm
sorry there was some those chess
whatever variance I usually don't like
the only ones that I like is it's crazy
house and and then back house and I
think this is actually quite interesting
even in some cases to play once in a
while I don't like it if it has like
nothing to do with chess like old
yeah those buzzer games don't go well
somehow I think I'm a bit too hasty in
the opening playing playing a bit too
quickly
and it was a bad idea actually no but it
wasn't exactly great technical player
blick but probably it's still enough
[Music]
yeah Blake is winning him unfortunately
yeah you can you can just donate by
paypal I think that God didn't go too
well
I probably should get more donation
options on but Simon the drunk chest ute
so we have a have a typical leave going
on with d3 let's see what happens I try
to play with creature f3 Knight to g4
yeah hello to John sucked and thanks for
the subscription before yeah then it's
bad luck if your eyes are annoyed by the
pset I'm sorry I'm it's just what I
would have chose to take so now this
this was kind of helpful for me this is
a really good diagonal and I've got like
g5 on the cards okay now I don't want to
trade Queens but this is kind of weird
yeah I rock do you wonder what was
already possible but this is a good move
anyway hmm I have g5 Knight f6 coming
Luffy code for black to make a move it
could be I'm sorry
yeah I'm just going to play it simple
yeah Knight age six was good but this is
a very simple wind so why not take it
okay
yeah playing as simply as possible just
double attacking yeah and this is not
really difficult to win forty seconds is
a little little bit it's not much not
safe but should just avoid stalemates
I'm really good at data allowing
stalemates in such a situation but I
think it should be avoidable okay so
back to the tournament I'm on fourth
place and yeah suffered two losses
against the high rated guys trying to
play a little bit more actively here
than in them that is normal let's aim is
opening yeah we have a typical question
if Fisher and his best would play a
match with Collins today what would be
the outcome yeah this is the typical
time treble time travel problem yeah if
you just put Fischer in a time machine
with no modern information he would lose
that match extremely clearly like
without any chance and the other
circumstances
tough to tell here have the fantastic
night only fire them that's really good
to have covers f7
not easy for y to find a plenum
can I got some dropped frames Wow
I hope that isn't a serious issue do you
see any me alright doesn't sound good
yeah with dropped frames okay so I'm
trying to get something on the G file
Oh interesting
I don't know politics improves the pawn
structure a little bit but okay I want
to get the pawns rollin it improves his
bishop slightly but I want King d65 and
so on I keep dropping some frames that's
pretty annoying my connection fields
reasonably steady okay can i drum up
something here
yeah I will I'm better in this ending
would not necessarily win
which one going to play a big porn
Center he is rolling floured rolling
rolling rolling yep
Jim between here with the frame drops
okay I want six plays still somewhat in
the hunt here in store so some hope with
lurking all games after me I have to
score against those top guys just not so
easy with the berserk yeah thanks for
donation
no I happen to analyze so look at any of
our four zeroes games I looked at the
games like just like a lot of interests
of course but I didn't invest much time
it's um yeah definitely interesting to
to see how them how this engine is
playing
don't know I don't like this position
all that much but something not h5 of
the funny idea I need to prevent 5:45 is
good for black in the standard Sassoon I
don't know what standards a scientist if
you mean the Kalashnikov variation I
think this is a fine fine variation to
find opening I have plated myself
I never recommended it to two students
it's not going to be easy
mmm don't like my position all that much
I don't know Bishop age 4 looks annoying
bishop age find go on the dark squeeze
it is judge I don't know look g8 doesn't
3 threaten much don't know what Ruby age
for does look aged 5 perceptive idea I
don't know I had to had to be quick of
course right coming quick Oh be dead
ok I have this one now it was an idea
anyway getting hook f6 into the mix
somehow I also could have checked which
would have been a good idea how did you
improve your middle gameplay that's a
good question yeah I was always I can
actually still casts a long which is a
really cool movie I don't know if it's
good but it's the kind of movie you know
you want to play if you see it is that
it is in the position yeah probably not
the best of ideas but it was cool to
play the routine ourselves shake him
shaky I I did and what I did was some
studying lots of full games lots of food
games master games classical games and
you learn so many patterns yeah this is
the strong so I guess I don't see a maid
down maybe it's not a strong
how is it checkmating me I don't see it
I think I can escape like hear one chick
and I have g7 yeah what is your job my
job is is chassis I'm mostly teaching or
working on chess content yeah so I'm I'm
still near a new tank box but he's
winning every game and I lost those two
berserks against a stronger stronger
Foreman's
again was locking us again so he's going
to go g6 and he places 96 again now I'm
going to go for Benoni style position
interesting way okay this is
this is good for white but you still
have to make all those moves
soon I was thinking Queen a3 but this
isn't actually working Queen is three
[Music]
now okay I was too quick over decision
and now it's getting away with this bad
opening it really is a bad opening
everything else would be too nice
okay mayor should shut up resort you
know just play a play a normal game and
refute this stuff and now you're sitting
there you're worse after f5 which
doesn't even play
[Music]
yeah this is this idea fancy idea and
it's not bad it's not bad
it's it's a very bad position yeah no no
okay if I play him again I will not
bezerk and just win the game it will be
better so I said before the tournament
that I want you to desert every game so
what a question of why it was a decision
that I made before the tournament and
see what happens
this or buzzer I mean I've done this in
other tournaments successfully but this
is a bit stronger then then the events
that I did this perform
yeah it's kind of acceptable this
pollution it's nothing special but it's
okay I know it looks a lot like you but
no name left yeah it's a good move by
Utah Wow
failing to pronounce it you tell him
something
I actually feel they're playing rather
well yeah getting not good positions out
of the opening and then playing really
well I mean this is he plays a really
good game in Utah something really good
game I'm just worse in this position I'm
just worse okay
I'm not unhappy about that in general
it's still nothing great
this should no I cannot really miss this
thinking of the bishop but c4 is hanging
so now I could could exchange then I go
up yeah video keeps freezing yeah I'm
sorry I somehow have dropped frames and
I don't really know why my connection is
generally speaking quite okay I mean I'm
getting a better internet connection
anyway I hope in the in the nearest
future bird
it takes a while
yeah really a bad position you Tom
something completely outplayed me in
this game really nice job it's not even
taking much time really good game I'm
like yeah just a very good game
no mistakes nothing really great nice
really nicely played
I mean okay they were joking is um it
takes a toll but I would really like to
have a better quality stream this is I
really hate I constantly get alarm
messages like your stream dropped and so
on this is really more knowing than
anything I'd not much I don't see what I
can do them
yeah I'm teaching a lot right it's just
I work more hours than a regular let
same office job would would would take
em I mean if you're in an office doing
whatever you have like you're 40 hours I
just work a lot more and I'm playing a
really crap yeah really really badly
the noise me of it yes that I'm not
playing better
that's not not not good here what I'm
doing I thought it was a really weird
play where black h4 h5 maybe doesn't
doesn't help much though he's six
doesn't work it doesn't work either I
can take it let's do this
try to get there five square probably
played six he mm-hmm
I didn't have much time quite clearly
not good not good at all and good play
ever black that was not a great position
and he defends is really good
justjust like a gamble here I have four
seconds left that won't work
Queen d5 probably completely lost here
at this one
she takes at Queen g6 we'll win I'm
going to get this on time which was
extremely I went offline
I'd reconnected now it's reconnected I
think shall I
I know
I have huge drops me
yeah I think I'm I reconnected him yeah
I think I should be back on right I have
700 frames dropped what what is this
crap oh my goodness I really hate this
friggin provider I really hate this I
don't see what I can do about it I can't
be start to [ __ ] rude it but it's
[Music]
yeah I don't know what I should do
I can I can restart the router
I got constant frame drops here and this
is like completely annoying of course I
mean I cannot I cannot play ready
because I keep staring at her stuff but
yeah what can you do it's currently have
cable cable internet and I don't know
why it is working so badly it's not
exactly a cheap connection or anything
like that it's just like yeah I hope
this change of provider will will help
yeah media should simply restart restart
the room I don't know what do you think
it might take some minutes and then I'm
back I don't know but this this way it's
commits going off and on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so hello and welcome again I restarted I
restarted the Rooter and I hope it works
better now it's just a matter of luck
yeah and see if it if it works or not if
I get dropped frames again I don't see I
don't see what I can do about it
so let's have a look there there are
these super blitz arena I paused the
tournament I actually resigned the last
game because that wasn't the priority
anymore so I don't think it and doesn't
really matter if I rejoined us again or
what with the five minutes left
let's um do some viewer games I'm not
joining this for one more game it
doesn't make any sense it didn't work so
well yeah with the buzzer King but well
last couple of games I was just staring
at the rock frames anyway so let's see
let's go with some viewer games please
challenge me and make it a blitz time
control yeah something that here like
adds up to 5 3 plus 2 5 plus 0 3 plus 0
or something like that and let's play
chess fast 1 2 3 you can challenge me
rated or unrated both is completely fine
going for a DDoS defense here with 5 to
come and thanks for the subscription
crazy Mike
yes I got the philidor's I should shut
the door the Reuters and the room next
to me yeah I really hope that this
internet connection issues will stop
with my new provider this is so
absolutely unacceptable
so Ches fast I went for an interesting
line at night to be 60 someone that I
recently yeah that recently came to my
attention when I studied the when I
looked at my you form a repertoire for
IB should you form us but I looked at
the affordable travel White Knight to d5
who not sure he just wants to take the
c7 home probably who came so when I
scrap here played Bishop f6 okay so
where are you going with this with the
Queen here I don't quite know a five is
interesting taking the Queen
yeah good good night
yeah the stream is it's late it's the
Late Show so I completely understand if
you don't watch the the whole thing and
say okay however it is fine so and what
to do here I can go be six keep this
part upon as a checked
yeah if is this issue yeah I didn't I
mean I saw that it was coming very
contacts no I never thought about it I
actually always liked I think it's ok
with the glasses I think what what is
worth considering is to do those what is
that acidity those those laser operation
there so that you don't have to wear
anything at all but in general I'm not
opposed I don't dislike the the glasses
yeah I went into this and now I have a
really terrible position I mean I saw
that if I was coming but somehow I
didn't react to it this is always the
worst
Oh another mall slipping ok ok I have to
really focus it really near no rematch
please I really need to focus here this
was a really terrible game so let's
focus
and kind of distracted by the whole
technical issues but sir I should play
better chess
Lord Kinbote ah let's see plays with
five so here I think d6 is correct yeah
thanks for subscribing move 11 huh I
can't go back right
yeah I'm not really considering at this
kind of laser operation a teammate of
mine had this done last year and that's
actually not true it was two years ago
I'm sorry and he's very happy with the
result but it's not something I consider
with him yeah here I don't see exactly
where Lord Kinbote his compensation as I
have grabbed this pond and is that a big
compensation
93 and maybe tries to get this back this
way I can go look at the age but he can
still try to take it takes takes takes
takes at the end see for Hank so it
shouldn't work I think I still keep this
pawn I still have to sort my position a
little but it's not extremely ammonius
yeah I lost one hundred fifty one was
lost fifty viewers with the technical
issues it's really really ashamed okay
let's develop
okay mmhmm yeah White is still
reasonably active him definitely
how did her to play the sign he's got
all these active pieces so not totally
clear in 5a for maybe try this if I get
I get this away from the e-file looks a
tad annoying them I don't really see how
I keep the pawn in the long run at d1 I
was back to expect that let's see okay I
think I should take this tempo and now
how to do that if I am let's try it and
now this Knight is now not pinned
anymore like this and then it's got
bishop g3 hmm it's still not entirely
easy maybe just rookie and oh yeah
that's not too bad I hope that's good
trade trade a bit more but Lord keyboard
is doing good job him really I think the
opening was less than ideal but he's
defending well after after the opening
didn't go so great for him someone queen
here
it puts the night onto you for for
example this is not going to be so easy
okay this is helping me quite a bit I
think then improves my my structure
enormous limb which is p.m. I switch
into am currently again with with cable
this is here from Germany its unity
medium and I'm switching back to the
telecom I've I've been quite happy with
my cable internet at my would place like
back in the city where I was living
before I moved here and it really got
terribly it was it was getting worse and
worse
and I really have to switch it's just
not good quality and I'm not sure that
the other other provider would be a lot
better in you I think you cannot be sure
about it really but well at least
they're cheaper that's because they give
they give you a discount if you if you
go for a new contract no the emotes I
didn't I didn't get to do it I didn't
get to do the emotes I'm sorry Sookie
magnets I wanted to do that yesterday
but it didn't work out our match was so
long I was wanted to do that in the
evening they didn't didn't quite manage
but I have time tomorrow and on
Wednesday so this should should
absolutely work that was a question
yeah and I can know it's it's it's okay
to talk about it
the the ICC simply terminated all the
weekly shows absolutely all the weekly
shows there is simply nothing nothing
left so there was blue show there was
some I 92 is actually better and anyway
Dooley's show there was John Watson show
my show
they all got terminated and it was some
it's fairly easy to explain it's just
that they felt that the show's yet
didn't help them all that much I mean
basically they offered them for free and
so they they felt they should should
stop them anyway it's a business
decision and in fact in terms of you
account my shows were pretty pretty
popular so it's not really let's say
something where I feel I should have
done something different something else
whatever it was it was okay but it
ultimately was not meant to meant to
stay that same
yeah mated 47 is doing a good job here I
actually made a mistake and moved a bit
too quickly here
I should go Knight to e2 this is a
better move and I just simply played 94
too quickly so he is attacking my bishop
and the pawn also I'm going back I'm
keeping my bishop am as long as I
possibly can oh there is a mate in 546
for 545 moves this is kind of crazy I
know what there was a or is I'm sure
maybe he's still as active um there was
a there was a problem composer who was
focusing on those kind of those kind of
problems thanks for following killer
cats I think he's also a streamer right
OC 5 that g5 I covered I don't think it
was hanging
yeah I think I'm going back yeah okay
there's there's a difference yeah with
the with the streams
I see seats ICC installed streams and
basically I'm they they they and they
hired people to do them and the streams
here on on chess calm I mean the beach
has streams are simply something that is
another thing so that she and watching
Boden this is something that is not like
him somehow initiated by the server it's
just like done by people who like to
stream so it's a different different
kind of situation so here what is this
Bishop g7 said something that I should
do probably not yeah I should rather
activate this Bishop okay I can take b7
why not I'll take it
I will take it I can take g3 this is
actually not super easy yeah for
improved in that service thank you
I really hope it improves when I get the
new SP it will be end of February I was
actually thinking of calling them and
trying to get that quicker but I guess
it won't help all that much and it was
kind of okay in the last week I had a
tech guy over here last week and he
changed something gave me new cables
whatever but it doesn't seem to it was
not a real solution to everything and
not so easy now for him I'm attacking
this and now it's a bit off
and he's struggling a bit keep this keep
this coordinated I wonder what's the
easiest way is technically to win a rope
trade would be nice and let's prevent a
three
I also good Afghan look a seven
a bishop d4 actually would have been a
good move
so I liked a bit too late
noise issues like on my end
really I don't hear anything
well you mean something with with the
internet so I did this why this Magnus
doesn't play online so much yeah when
he's got stuff to do right I mean I
actually think you plays quite a bit
online yeah all those D plays the
tournaments on the chest once in a while
when there are when they have the bullet
tournaments or you playstyle tuesdays
and stuff so yeah he plays he plays
quite a bit online I mean he has to work
a bit on his chest and also do the odd
non chest thing I guess so playing Alex
machine him and we have four nights with
black here you can actually play this
which is kind of funny this is the
Halloween gambit with black and in fact
this is better than this is better than
the Halloween gambit with with white
because now this night wolf is not
possible I don't know
efore deform I think he falls right
young or deform I think it both kind of
works
actually this has been played by Magnus
cards near when he was a kid with black
so it's not it's not completely
ridiculous I wonder if this is right
though I think they're deflecting I
think he recently returns it returns to
peace it's not a bad decision from a
practical point of view yeah I think it
was d4 and they're five yeah I think I
screwed it up a little bit so what's
going on here Bishop to e6 I can't go 94
but then there's a check on e3
these this works
no I had thought it's not a computer I
guess I came this was a good move though
and he's attacking d5 hmm this looks
extremely slow let's do that this is so
funny it's funny wolf taking this
preparing c6 it's kind of yeah it
doesn't look like it should work hands
for some reason but how exactly does he
play now mayhap this is the thing I
probably had to do that so covering this
yes yeah this now three-30 is fine of
course yeah as long as we don't make it
like not 5+3 or something there is a bit
too long with other all those challenges
so Bishop d7 I really want to get
castled
I know the night looks funny but it's
not so bad because you can sometimes put
it here three six which is a quite good
position for it interesting player right
I think that was good
yeah today today I had a chance lesson
and it was interesting because I
discussed with my student taking towards
the center and away from the center and
I said that probably there are more
cases where I kept away capturing away
from the center is stronger than
capturing towards the center and I'm not
sure it could be possible this eight is
taking towards the center is really
really old rule yeah I think taking on
g6 wasn't such a great decision I have
really nice play now good evening
to kul up we have to find I hope you are
fine as well I know you're often on in
the early streams even on the morning
streams yeah I'm having quite some
pressure here it's not so easy to play
now how does he keep everything covered
I don't see how exactly Queeny one
keeping f2 and the rook not not a nice
position to play
smart chick get the nitrite into White's
position said three plus two is so white
should not lose on time okay nice nicely
defended it's a I mean I'm fine but it's
not like an easy win I can check kingi
three threatening would be two now small
tactics yeah I could have taken g2 I
know when upon but I didn't want her
upon was didn't seem enough okay John
was in yo yeah hello to the drunken
lawyer welcome to the chat late join but
ok F this is the life of someone at
university okay Jonesy no what are you
doing is talks a lot like a bike madam
again but this is a good line against a
black Madiba
I think like it's just in very good
shape Bishop g5 interesting okay
[Music]
yeah um I definitely have ideas to do a
subscriber and do things for subscribers
but I already am an affiliate so you can
already subscribe partnership is I think
a little bit a little bit more
privileged but I'm not so sure about the
differences to be honest so taking this
and now what to do here I can let's just
cancel and go f6
yeah the black MIDI my gambit is just
not really a good opening it's just what
it is
f6 this line here with c6 is really good
against it it's something that I looked
at some years ago I had to check on a6
show but check is also pretty strong
yes I guess ago or German I am wrote a
book on the black Medina gambit and
there was always violent I mean and this
is a good player so there has to be some
point to it
but I'm not quite sure what it is
so when it's chick-chick first yes I'm
not so far away from the from the
partnership and on Twitch I know just a
couple of streams weekly will will do it
know there was a there was a book on the
black MIDI Megan by Christophe Shira is
a good player it's a very decent I am I
played against him in the German
championship some years ago and so ways
that shake made that I should have this
is probably going to die made soonish
not sure if there was a quicker one now
I don't have any grandmaster knows
[Music]
yeah thanks for subscribing cool hope
soonish yeah it's a it's an interesting
word I am obviously I picked that up
from Peter Svidler yeah yeah I mean I
have to admit that and I'm just taking
for granted that it is proper English
but I'm not not saying I know that was
shown Paul Morphy another cool username
let's play the helices against Palmer
feel ok yeah also I was fairly sure that
it is a proper proper Englishman hog
would win an Enzo alhasan themed
tournament that's a cool question maybe
he's got lots of experience yeah that
guy always plays one B 3 so I'm going to
tip here and push before that cannot
possibly be bad
shop cheap chip asks do you have a
pension plan
oh wow you guys care for for my
well-being
do you want to sell me a pension plan
that the better
no I'm I think I'm okay really
so okay okay eight I mean if I get a
night to be three this is this is just
fantastic
this is fantastic
this is that this is really not a good
Bishop
yes this bishop will indeed not be good
yeah it's funny it's funny that he has a
hard time to play like c4 Bishop b2 the
knight on d3 is just too strong
I have Knight f4 and then possibly
taking but this Bishop to have one at
the end I don't want that to happen
so okay I'm simply stopping this
I'm completely stopping this like b5 I'm
not giving him this opportunity a still
cannot go B should be too
yes this is funny I'm sorry I'm a bit
sadistic yeah I have to have to admit
that but this is like this is so crazy
because why this is close to the suits
one where is he putting his his pieces
let's see yeah how can you get him into
some completes of this one I mean I can
take on before and win but I cannot
stick here okay I'm ending the sad life
of this Bishop okay
you get happy lot adverts what is what
is that who have lot what is that I
fancy watch okay yeah I think I've heard
about that yeah that's room so I don't
have a fancy watch
but I'm happy I've got I've gotten I
recently switched back to analog watch
it's nice it gets nice to where instead
of an electronic device
so now bill Gus on chess is going to go
III okay
[Music]
okay probably the fibre that cannot be
bad going for like a classical setup d5
c5 we just takes yes yes I had a I had a
I had an Apple watch
the most beautiful 60 year 60 plus year
old women in the world of chess
60 plus Wow whether they would have unis
you need to give me suggestions
suggestions them
no I'm not going to read the name okay
so II for was played him and they have
to figure out what to do again said I
don't want to take and a default problem
but it could play bye-bye white we have
in the burden candidates tough to say
yeah I have this mean it says what I
want to win or where think will win I'm
hoping for Aronian really
I always liked his play and he's a he's
a nice guy I feel so why not
um I interesting
gas switching back from an Apple watch
to analog watch doesn't really say so
much about Apple it's just it's just
what watching what do you want to do
with a watch it's the thing I think that
um that um I like the watch the Apple
watch the thing is it is okay with what
it is doing I just felt that I don't
need the stuff that it does because for
example you get all those some messages
like yeah you have a let's say whatsapp
message you have an email coming in
stuff like that and I felt that was
mostly annoying me and yeah so I felt it
is just not helping me in a way I at the
beginning I felt it is no I can take
here actually right and then take it to
at the very beginning I like that I was
like getting the messages and I'm
informed about stuff but it well at some
point you think okay I just don't want
to get any messages yeah
so yeah my night is not good try to get
it to before be sure I don't I don't
mind I would play any level of player
also and I am why not
is there any I am challenging it's it's
just a long list you know getting to be
tough to manage Oh 21 seconds you're
completely right I have to make sure
that the time is okay I don't like
watches that are too clunky when I
currently have is a bit design
middle-of-the-road what it's not
extremely bulky Queen h5 made yeah that
helps when you're low on time so here we
go let's play so what is a good question
and too many questions
crgo challenge me with Sergio and yeah
the my opponent is not playing so can
always reach allenge I don't see and I
am challenging me
the dear santa-claus maybe I don't know
yes do you play on chess calm no I don't
I I was actually when I was thinking of
doing streams you know the early early
this year the the main question for me
was to a stream here on leeches or do a
stream on chest or cones and I decided
to stick with leeches because I like the
playing experience more I think it just
thought calm should improve the
interface and I don't I don't really
have that much fun playing there it's
not terrible I mean really not terrible
but it's also not great for me I think
in terms of pure playing experience and
leech SS excellent and I felt I'm
staying here I don't know I don't want
to this is not a decision like for the
rest of my life
but it is currently I just enjoy playing
here more so a good play here by my
opponent my hmm
I wonder how to play this how can i how
do I play this kind of position it's not
yet hanging pawns let's see the C go for
c5 I can take 94 then but it's um it's
not clear that he has to do that I can
also play play with B 4 B 4 a 4 stuff Oh
could be an idea ok now he goes for this
and now I'm on this I think too many
times it's it's a bit it's a bit tough
to meet all the more the text ok I can
take here right I will do so yeah this
is the the leech has platform is just
incredibly smooth I mean it works so
well I only think that when they have
the the the title tournaments I think
somehow you you you feel it in server
node but other than that it's super
smooth ok um Quincy form
[Music]
aerotyne don't do that too often
oh it's actually true
I know okay it's a good game I mean it's
a good position anyway I don't need to
win a piece necessarily this is actually
white sheep it looks green but you know
it's the white tea and green tea are
quite similar okay
Knight to c4 this is just a really nice
position yeah they're my the main income
that magnus carlsen
has is actually from the from the FM the
play magnus app it's easy to check if
you are interested because Norway has
this this policy that you can see
everybody's income it's completely
public so everybody can look it up yeah
thanks for donating a sub cool okay
where do I go to c6
let's not let's not do that too quickly
okay it's not it's it's nice it is nice
thanks for the cheer so how long will
you stream I was thinking like up to
1:00 a.m. but maybe I can do a little
bit more it's a really nice view count
and that oh that's a check I do have
something I can play for checkmater h4
h5 is made you can try that I stay I
made somewhere like here if he takes
mate is just around to call out of it he
does not have to unfortunately
so not a meat hanging in there hmm yeah
there are many ways to be better wasn't
sure what is best but this looks looks
looks okay really
let's think about this form for movement
that's it we 494 check that's not so
great actually
before you sighs immediately what check
here aged six takes King F six that's it
that should be fine
maybe I should maybe I could have played
this better I mean okay maybe is wrong I
could have played this better this is
almost I'm almost sure about that but I
still think it should win I'm thankful
subscribing spell spell spell okay yeah
thanks for the game my hmm
ya know it's really tough there was an
IM challenging I am your father
let's do that play the fellow I am here
who is that actually is their name in
death so I'm going one in form and test
the entire Sicilian repertoire
I'm your father is that from Star Wars
yeah
Duke I'm your father I keep forgetting
how this actually works no I'm not going
to
it's a funny question no I'm not going
to tell you what I make with chess a
year but you can be ok but I'm not sure
what you're playing level is and so on
what you have to accept this unless
you're an extremely strong player I mean
like yeah extremely strong yeah you have
to work a lot really a lot well what you
what you do is and you work and I hope
something that you that you like to do
so this is an important consideration so
I took on d4 and yeah this this kind of
structural change is not I'm not really
am opposed that opposed to that let's go
back
an interesting way of playing this I
think I go EV form
I'm really not interested in those chess
variants I don't know them well and it's
not really I don't really look into this
at all so let's see yeah
tried to play 93 and a five-year I
didn't play this well I think I screwed
up the move order in the opening it's
still interesting oh not not a move that
I expected but interesting okay I'm
taking if he takes with the pawn a
knight c5 is a move I just wonder what
this is this is a good move or not yeah
I think I should take it I don't see why
I shouldn't Queen takes rook chicks Oh
Queen c3 is a move that I missed
actually ah it's got Queen c3 yeah
Quincy three and mr. smooth rupee one
Quincy - and I'm toast
I think he I mean sorry I think he
stumbled into that yeah Quincy 3 Quincy
- I'm okay I have a tempo I can play
Bishop a3 or whatever but this is this
is winning from like that's just winning
from like now that that's really stupid
yeah I'm heavily underrated here on that
side I never play blitz really yeah and
this is this is good now a black is
winning I have no way of from I've never
no way of saving this ready okay one I
can go where this is a second I have to
do it
why not this should be - did I have that
marouk were saying okay so rupee ain't
I don't like this position
so I think yeah this is going to be
awful okay Ruby - I cannot blame
and no I don't think my rating is always
been what's more slower here anyway
well I can take on age six why not at
least that develops I'm attacking the
rook here okay so we have this chick is
extremely extremely annoying
my queen doesn't have all that many
squares okay
threatening look see one you'll see one
is going to get this trade
there's a stream that Kings crush is
speaking Spanish that sounds funny it
really sounds funny I didn't know that
that he was speaking Spanish at all
okay now I'm losing this game he's
playing as well
okay so resign the reason I have to
confirm that yeah good game but I'm your
father I think I don't want to really do
a rematch it's um too many challenges so
I don't want to just want to really go
for one one one game per player yeah
yeah yeah go so some data stream in
Spanish
and he did commentary in Spanish but I
think he speaks decent Spanish as far as
I know that could be could be wrong
that's what I heard I cannot really
evaluated okay
that's looks nice I like this position
it looks like a good term anti-tarnish
let's say could crumb they pull an upset
in the candidates I mean I would be
surprised if you would window more thing
I have to say I would be somewhat
surprised to see that oh it's been a fan
of chronic stress really since the very
beginning but I still would be surprised
it's something that the other players I
think they're a bit more a bit sharper
at the moment but you you never know
it's just like two or three weeks let's
say where you have to have to BM in top
shape and that can always happen so I'm
going to keep this no Kramnik doesn't
have a dry style this is not the case
very much you have to I mean what he did
is he had a face time spent where he was
playing extremely solidly right after
the the Kasparov match but but in recent
years no it's one of the I think more
creative players for him he brought many
many interesting opening ideas
on the map and even in opening lines
that don't really feel interesting like
the London system that was also
something that Kramnik reintroduced and
with actually many interesting ideas so
we're taking here with the points on the
queenside
my last over the board tournament I was
playing the open tournament in Krakow
Poland and John that was some young late
2017 early 2018 didn't do all that well
but it was a that that's a tournament I
can definitely Wow what's happening here
I definitely can recommend it so it's a
good tournament to plane and crack I was
really a good place to visit so yeah I
think it's tough for him to keep his
material him many rooks hanging less
bickering mate yeah you don't have that
that's a good question who's what what
kind of grandmasters what super GM is
Supes what it's closest to having a very
neat very ation named after himself you
don't see that too often right it's
really it doesn't happen all that much
nowadays there are new opening
inventions all the time I think Joe
voila you know he's got this Joe Baba
opening d4 Knight c3 Bishop f4 this is
something that definitely yeah it's
named after him I wonder if he's going
for each form and who's sending me
messages so here
indeed five let's do this
cocking will win the candidates again
yeah no offense taken but um and this is
one of the outcomes that I really hope
won't happen because I really felt that
this was a rather boring match and it
was simply the kayaking cars and match
it was a match of two players of a very
very similar style in fact and I think I
think a new match wouldn't be very
exciting this is not really something
personal like like just that I didn't
like that match so much it was not very
interesting
swish sneak off is still alive that's
absolutely true yes
keeps writing opening books so let's go
before rush this is what you like here
in the leningrad touch strong bishop
yeah that was an interesting discussion
yeah maybe going back to this world set
we're drawn match let's the champion
keep the title so that it then it
encourages more fighting chess
interesting yeah that's I think it's an
interesting idea and so but however I
think like in modern times it feels a
bit weird to give somebody rods I think
it's very tough to to sell to the
general public that is not really so
much into chess
okay so I've got a nice position here
but how do you actually do this yeah
that is something there's something
about that yep
Magnus is winning every tie break he's
simply the best reputable it's player I
actually think of all-time by some
margin it's fantastic what he does in
those super strong as a super quick and
sweet time controls it's really
remarkable so if I go Queen to d2 here
yeah let's do it
that must be a good ending yeah okay
and now what taking this taking this so
that was submission oh wow I did not see
that one coming
woo
I completely overlooked that interesting
[Music]
when in when in doubt give a check
in southern or to will no I can go look
the to and be upon up especially calm is
not out of fashion the problem is nobody
allows it because it's so good this is
the thing they are played Bishop b5 and
necessary and and there's a reason for
it and that is called sveshnikov oh that
was that was helpful
I've got thirty thirty challenges I can
never play all of them
so in d4 against actual but it's not
replied not playing no I'm not taking
some Red Bull I don't know I think I
tried vent bull once in my life and no
not my not my kind of kind of thing
yeah you can play with C form against
the specialty coffee but it is it is
also capable Ike I mean the we had some
we had this in the World Championship
match between them cool let's tell me
almond and Guilford so and even this she
didn't get anything and then switched to
the Rosalie more so he Archer oh I've
got a nice position here with a full
Center and the bishop am yeah
give give that to chrome negative will
win give that to me and I will try at
least okay
actually playing this is a good idea
doing something against my centum so
let's do that
yeah I don't know Red Bull I'm kind of
skeptical about those things
yeah I do enjoy an alcoholic beverage
from time to time but really not that
often actor is really taking his time he
said increment it is important to note
so how would you play to prevent any
night see for stuff
yeah only in in recent weeks did I start
to drink that much tea and it's um it's
really a good good beverage got lots of
variety you can get all kinds of team
and it's um I think it's not not bad to
do especially in them like in the winter
well it's quite enjoyable to have some
warmth so um let's see what to do here
I'm pinning him I try to play a 690 form
TS got caffeine of course it depends on
the tea of course but most of it does so
yeah h5 that's a good move I did not
really anticipate that not-so-nice good
play age 5 I may be a handy 6 I'd really
irritated me I had he 6 yeah and now
this is not so good ring I did blunder
that porn basically
that was sick
what what did I do here I blunder my big
center pond hmm what tea of course
contains caffeine what are you talking
about it depends again on the if you
have like a fruit-based see it doesn't
but black tea contains caffeine even
even green and white tea does it is not
such as not that much
so not so nice yeah I definitely don't
deserve to win this game
and the position is a complete drawer so
I'm going to offer I draw here really
may decline to two drawers that's kind
of funny because I'm not going to lose
this position ever I need to click two
times I'm sorry yeah this is important
yeah I have to click it which I'm sorry
so I came so with dear Santa Claus it's
such a long list I really feel bad for
not playing everybody but let's see yeah
yeah you have to click twice
I came yeah this is a and this is a
pretty high rated player I'm actually
rating underdog them
yeah thanks for the game
doctor oh and no Bishop g5 I'm playing
superficially have come on
just playing too quickly and too
superficially that's a very bad position
or a
hmm it's not playing Bishop cakes of six
interesting okay
94 is probably going to plain normal 92
yeah I still have to do it then I'd be a
don 97 just looks too sad that's a bit
too sad yeah that opening really went
wrong it went wrong
d6 was a really mr. booth
yeah what has to decide if he wants to
take yeah this yeah
Queen to b3 maybe well three to do four
not the most obvious move ever
I have Queen a5 in this position and aft
captures capturing is an interesting
option actually take when a five f4 but
he's got f4 then I have the chick that
doesn't help
let's do this probably be should be
three you're me how is he doing it it's
a double at check essentially what
triple attack yeah something like that
wonder what he does Bishop III maybe
simply and then I wanted to take
interesting interesting position
now I don't know what white why should
do you stay another rule besides Bishop
III ff4 that's a kind of move I really
have trouble believing
Quincy for whom no not so much
I don't really the question was if I
enjoy motor racing like Lamar or Formula
One no not not that much what I what I
actually do watches some stuff like yeah
former the original Top Gear show are
now the Grand Tour
I have watched stuff like that it's kind
of silly and the who but it's it's
entertaining I think I'm fine him white
cannot castle so yeah I've got f5 but he
might take it twice and then simply
castle
yeah not sure that this was great I like
the Queen here and this he has to cheat
with if I if I if I if I take this
adding some music oh no I don't think
this is a great idea
we have caught all kinds of copyright
problems right with music and I'm just
winning this book now on stuff what do I
win here take yeah this is easiest just
take it and do this
yeah well what I did was winning the
Queen I think it was okay so um so a
Lord Kinbote or didn't we play earlier I
think we did yeah
Oh what a what a long list you know okay
so let's go play Pet that sets the
greatest donation ever it's really
really cool
thanks for the relation woody Gus
yeah this was really really cool so yeah
the message was you're far superior
player than me that was really nice but
I can't be sure to do this is the main
line and I keep forgetting my own stuff
I think I recommended d6 did I recommend
that I don't remember I don't remember I
don't recall it said Peter Gabriel
always said Genesis
I think it's Peter Gabriel right
yeah is this still a fairly good
compensation I think 94 to e5 maybe
let's try that
so I would idea of Nigel
is to do this okay he wants to go 95
which is a in general a good idea I
think really I think the the challenges
on top are the oldest this is what I
this is what I wanted to do isn't that
giving me be - that was the idea of
playing b3 that I can actually take this
Bishop's III Wow
[Music]
if I take B 1 and then a 4 what is the
drawback okay I wonder about this I take
a for now is that it can take g7 no I
don't see the big point I think I can
take it
and I'm attacking eform so it's not like
he asks all the time now so the Banco
did strike and I won both pawns a pawn
and beep on good stuff I don't have any
tea left I think this is a drawback
little bit but not much
ok h3 yeah if I drop back to f6
I might just win more pawns right I
think I do smoke crafts sd-6 I did
recommend that in fact so I wasn't
completely wrong about my own
recommendations hey this is a bit
difficult now I'm attacking this
yeah a temple and I'll take him
[Music]
yeah thanks also to all the new
followers and gained during that stream
yeah matzo we need some mods that's
probably true no joke but I think it's
so kind of civilized
so let's go even raiment so Yvonne
Yvonne Oh Raymond um no joke no joke is
on so I can play the other kinds just
for you
it's gone five
yeah this is a good outcome here I've
got this sent upon in effect that's
really nice
whoa what is he going to do against this
Wow it gives me it gives me the bishop
pair and the center again the same thing
that I had in this earlier game that's
really nice
the most views on twitch I think I had
close to 300 once Oh whoosh arrow time
[Music]
Bishop takes looks like look simple but
I wonder yeah 34 I've got 30 something
challenges really a lot yeah a winning
material analysis the easiest thing to
do I think what a gas donated tenure
stop impersonating me that's really cool
oh my goodness this is great stuff okay
so um Steven dealers know your
challenges right at the bottom so I'm
I'm doing it in the right order
basically with the older challenges
first which so in narrow
new account heard Island
what heard Ireland and McDonald's Island
in dinero is not playing so I'm going to
abort that one and go with sake making
nuggets that's kooky for here mix
openings close to 250 stream is already
on for longer than originally wanted but
the way I see it I can't sleep a bit
longer anyway tomorrow morning so it's
kind of came
eight-hour streams oh my goodness that's
something that's something for weekends
so a modern benoni I'm going to go with
this line I think this is a good line
for white
yeah it's later it's 1:00 1:30 almost in
the night
but it's okay but the first lesson
tomorrow at 1:00 p.m. so it's not not so
urgent to go to bed so I got before
properly covered and I try to maybe
traitors Sookie McNuggets this is three
point three plus zero or so no increment
you have to speed up a bit at least I
will be fine I was tough to play
actually preparing f4
he's going see form hmm okay going to
stop the bee pond with a five and black
has a bit of an issue to develop if it
was here I don't believe in that that I
will take how I don't like to give up my
bishop but it's an exchange more or less
without any clear compensation I think
yes
for lineup yeah I want to get the night
away from that active post and maybe
just win the c4 pawn
yeah maybe we get background music Alec
completely horrible computer game sounds
from the 80s or something that is
completely irritating really not sure
that how good that was no it looks ok
actually prepare until 5 now going 5 I
guess so this must be right simply
blasting everything open yeah thanks for
the aim silky McNuggets monomino is
always tough to handle
so let the meat heck what is let the
meat CAC what does CAC mean ok I'm going
for primo of g6
[Music]
what does he do let the meat kak-kek is
a frog okay hmm
let them eat cake yeah that that's
possible
[Laughter]
okay long sand let them eat cake
it was Marie Antoinette right French
Revolution time so let's go Lana srimant
gambit here against the know he takes it
okay this is not so terrible actually
yeah I know
let the meat cake that I know it was a
little bit it was a little bit more
complicated but this it is from from
that time so yeah this is probably more
natural Queen eight riders g6m that
doesn't work
Bishop f5 the screen to b5 check hmm
that's a little bit annoying so maybe
develop this first I'm a pretty sure g4
looks too awful I just noticed that
there was a bit too late I cannot take
it because of the pin
man I shouldn't have allowed that but
okay I still think I'm reasonably okay
how to do it Bishop d7 and then castle
[Music]
not some nice
I didn't you didn't play that well
allowing before was a pretty bad idea
you know white has this excellent square
in default that's important and you will
just guarantee him the better game yeah
not good oh that is surprising I thought
with just castling short white would be
comfortably better here I feel I get
some play
[Music]
yeah there's actually 96
96 and it's got the chick coming here
huh
the Grandmaster repertoire books any
opinions on down yeah these are the
books by quality chess yeah there are um
very good quality books quality chess is
kind of the right name for that
publishing company however what what you
have to have to say is that those books
are not formed for everyone
they are on an extremely high level and
I think they're oftentimes bought by
players who probably would benefit more
from yeah well not looking at openings
in the first place or get a somewhat
simpler book yeah it's just that they
are immensely complicated and at times
really tough to digest those books okay
I'm going for some counter play and I
hope getting something here with before
coming Bishop g4 maybe
f 3 is actually quite good for him let's
see pawn takes Bishop takes maybe they
move by move services by everyman I
guess and yeah something like that which
is a bit more one it's a bit more
compact I think oftentimes the better
choice it's just like those books are
great but you're not going to oh really
the chick in many cases you're just not
going to be able to simply remember all
the stuff I have Beckham some years ago
sorry when I got them English Grand
Master rapidly drop by marine I simply I
could not at all remember what he was
recommending it was just so complicated
and some other books are even even more
difficult like the King's Indian books
by Petronius for example which is not
grandmas repertoires to Tanya's on the
King's in years it's just like extremely
tough to to use that stuff
yeah the colonias books are oh my god I
got I got one or two of those and I
really felt like okay no way I'm I'm
going to remember this stuff
okay so I've set this up in a way that
he cannot take absolutely nothing yeah
knife to f5 this is exact être yes I
like that I like that it's a really good
way of putting it there with the knight
on f5 then they are really extremely
oops let's not remove sleep remove get
to the e3 pawn name is really hanging on
him
it's not increment self and yeah wide
resigned
how much an opening what what does the
difference to cheek
yeah oh no I'm sorry no no I'm not
playing hard it was accidental I'm sorry
the opening it's not a huge deal when
you are playing on a let's say on on the
club level or lower you need to still
think at that level you need to know a
little bit I mean not like books but I
think you should have an idea about the
first couple of moves what you're doing
and let's say if you are white you
shouldn't like think on the first move I
think you do something like decide if
you want to play a forward e4 and have
some kind of setup in mind this is I
think make sense on any sort of playing
level the opening is part of the game
and you should have some some idea what
what's going on but it's not like you
need complicated books at that at that
stage if you get better like 15 16 1700
you want to look at openings a little
bit more so we have thinking I'm going
to play for development here
this should give white excellent
development the queen basically has to
go back and then Bishop III it looks
extremely dangerous a six this was
weakening black quite a bit yeah thanks
for the game long said he's in the [ __ ]
okay arrow time cleric c1 and now where
is the Queen going
my it looks costly
it should be a full book actually the a
a look
yeah and bro Hanson resigned thanks for
the game yeah the city yo the challenge
count gets down a little bit
no thanks for following Jack handle tend
and CTO is going for electrons in tears
you know I am leech has patron that's
good to see any chances it's obviously a
free site but you can of course donate
and become a patron of the site and I
think it's a good idea to do that if you
really enjoy it
I don't know I'm petrol for I think 18
months something something like that and
it's I think it's it's a it's a good
thing to do especially if you use it a
lot I do all my chassis lessons on HS
and this was my main reason for donating
I use the platform basically on a daily
basis for hours and it's just an
extremely well made system there with
them with the with a studies the study
feature is fantastic I use it again all
the time
f7 is falling oh thanks for the donation
Jackie Jack Enlow 10 I have a feeling
you like math me wait I can take here
right and seat I resigned thanks for the
game ambitious chess why not um I'm not
really I didn't really look into math
since my school days I can actually I
can't handle no I have to do it I have
to do it differently I'm really not
great at math in a theoretical sense so
I cannot like do something complicated
because I stopped doing anything at
school yeah like right after I did
finish school I didn't look at math in a
theoretical sense at all but I have a
really good let's say feel for
mathematics if this is something yeah I
mean I've worked in in controlling for
four years in the bank and there was a
lot of a lot of mathematical stuff but
yeah more analytical sense like you have
a huge let's say yeah base of figures
and you need to read a pattern into it
or something like that I'm really good
at but I wouldn't be great at like
solving some complicated equation or so
not not not my thing
so this is a really somewhat complicated
rillette position
that's what I'm trying to say I can take
and queen g3 problem
yeah this is attacking here and the
Queen so black almost has to take and
well got the Queen's off I'm a pawn up
it looks nice maybe not the best
possible outcome but I'm certainly quite
fine him coming before Bishop f4 is also
a good move to attack this next
Yeji sixes is just a big porn oh then
I'm taking
[Music]
so this is looking really really really
weird for like what resins okay thanks
for the game ambitious chess Dark Knight
and many numbers okay so let's go in for
let's see what the Dark Knight is doing
yeah I wonder how long I'm going to
stream don't know it's tough to say I
enjoy playing those games and a slave
plenty of challenges
yeah I wonder
I wonder maybe this stream as long as
I've got more than 200 viewers
I don't know it could take a while them
so the Dark Knight is not moving
yeah here black plays Bishop deserve up
most of the time might have six and so
on
okay you wanna try to do this here black
usually goes a six Bishop af1 and Bishop
to g4 so it looks like he's going for
the theoretical line after all takes a
long time to play it down here black
mostly captures yep in g6 or e6 both are
okay
yeah the good good statement there in
the chat it's tough too tough to explain
okay so what is White's idea here I'm
going to move the hoops move the Queen
back I just wonder if I should go here
for maybe probably not so here at d4 is
my plan to get this and a 593 before a
Bab d4 at the end I get d4 in and with
the bishop pair white has a little bit
of an advantage it's not fantastic but
it's very comfortable to play
[Music]
and then default I just wanna should I
take on a eight host or play before
immediately this maybe is better if he
takes Queen a one is actually ready to
go here Quintus is seven interesting
yeah the challenge count is actually
going up top bad news per se but so what
am I doing here
wonder what to do huh
it's bishop city forward idea I wonder
if this is actually a point I'm not sure
about it placing my rook and a cost to
the Queen
let's do this I like this I like this
position it looks looks good
it's not easy okay no he takes it so
some quite happy about and he won't take
again that that will be bad on the sea
farm we should be five maybe I would be
a done hmm
hmm huh how to play this
oh no I think this is a perfect genome
again there's a suspicion that this is a
cheater I don't know blacks move seemed
fairly natural to me
and kill your sacrifice it's very close
a chick and then 95 Oh looks interesting
yeah this is coming the light squares a
week I saw this kind of idea when I
played Bishop c4 so we'll see how this
pans out but this is pretty dangerous
okay so night age seven I guess check
then he has to go Bishop f8 check and
this yeah that was just a normal player
there was no nothing going on them okay
so 42 challenges this is crazy
three plus three that's a bit long and
we have lots of long longest longest
challenges here I'm going to sorry I'm
going to cancer all the the non blitz
here that's it's too long
three plus three no not eight this one
three plus two is good so so let's see
Seema Seema Steen probably t5
yeah so we're going to probably
transpose into some French advance no as
I said this I actually looked yet does
that actually look that I'm on the
repertoire I not a six though we should
before it's kind of playable from like
not great but possible to play
yeah 95 what else
Oh going back
39 challenges that's crazy that's crazy
I don't even look tired
let's take that as a compliment I didn't
I mean I didn't work that much today it
was kind of okay yeah Harry the H pawn
right that's a bit difficult to like
yeah if he goes age five I've got Queen
f5 attacking f7 yeah that runs it to
this unfortunately
hmmm I wonder if he was going to be
eight I probably just take
Yeah right whitey have just very young
Leafs of regular green tea I am only
recently
yeah gotten into drinking tea so I
really new to that but in terms of
tastes I don't see a huge difference
between green tea and white tea maybe
I'm just not like getting it but it
stops it's not a huge use difference to
me in terms of taste yeah this is not
looking a gradient to black
like g 690 of six that will cost
material quite a bit
so night is six still sort of holding
for the moment I probably did something
wrong it shouldn't hold for the moment
Maya played this bat it I really played
this badly
I mean blacks position is not great but
it should be even worse I think
it's a bit of a weird think yeah it
starts with T then you're eating
biscuits and before you know it you're
British yeah it sounds funny okay rook
e8 yeah this is actually a move it is a
move I can't guess along rook takes
Queen takes is six is that something
that's a funny idea actually
but we've been in exchange let's do it
yeah if it takes with the pawn f7 will
win stuff and this is a fantastic
position yeah
and the the week back rang this is
completely winning I think yeah it's
it's I think you're pretty winning
thanks for the game seem esteem so brain
salad surgery let's go
brain salad surgery it for d4c fall it's
gotta fall and see what we can do here
what do we get Kings Angeles always good
to see I will very often get excellent
positions don't do we know of them but
openings usually work quite well there
yeah what is he doing h6 yeah black in
this some line the Petrosian should
actually be careful with the standard
King side attack because I have not
cancelled so in some cases black is
pushing pawns and doesn't really have a
clear target as my king is still only
one I have not yet Castle so let's see
what he does
f5 is kind of normal but they have f3
and so I think f4 now is yeah this is I
think questionable because again I'm not
canceling here in this position yeah I
can go B form because of that pin so ABA
B Knight X is not possible so I get
before in one move
yeah I had games where I play c5 9014 D
- [ __ ] yeah where are you from mr.
streamer and from Germany small town in
the western Germany the western part of
Germany so what is black going to do so
I can go c5 immediately or go Queen b3
or queen b1
they all make some sense let's go Queen
to b3 I'm lacking info on my stream for
people who don't know who I am like you
mean where exactly and like the screen
estate some some more information
maybe I just explained it in there
you're using to see my name
in Dutch Lots violets that's a funny way
of putting it Oh funny no I'm not from
Schwartz vault this watch watch what
valve is in southern Germany okay so
what's what's going on here c6 is the
normal way of playing this let's do it
and my twitch channel has links to my
Chester a rapper to us I don't think it
should be on the actual screen and B 5 I
was thinking should win win some
material
he's got Ruby aid but then I just moved
the queen it's still a fork
the black forest em Bishop c4 is also
kind of noise
I just move this out it should be good
so and I'm too greedy to not try to win
this exchange as well I still have not
cancelled again and brain salad surgery
resides I have an excellent I have an
excellent record with with the Trojan
variation Chakrapani fishy fishy
wasn't he the main he donated stuff
right for them for the 20 for the 24
hour streamer for pension who entertain
c4 was requested so I'm going to do it
when Chakrapani is playing
[Music]
okay I'm going for later
you want one later before in many cases
so rupee one yeah this is a line that I
had in my match estable repertoire I can
scourge for we can be very flexible here
with the white setup you can do many
things rupee one before a43 this is why
the English is a very popular opening at
the top level it's not so it's not so
much about forced lines and nowadays
they welcome that but they don't have
super forced variations but rather the
position that they can play where they
don't expect some deep preparation that
kills the game and in the English this
doesn't happen that much yeah you get
oftentimes positions with most of the
pieces still left on the board that are
going to be complicated long term okay
so what are we going to do here f4 is
something I like to play but I still
have time to prepare it okay let's go I
for now I've got most pieces set up
correctly for that it feels as bishop
looks like it doesn't it doesn't have
any squares I'm not yet threatening at
five I think material wise it wouldn't
woodwind material but okay if he feels
like he's a little bit afraid that
something bad might happen to him okay
let's do woopsie 195 oh why isn't that
blundering stuff
huh Knight takes pawn takes Bishop takes
Knight g4 check pawn takes Bishop takes
2 4 & 5 & 5 & f6
that's going to be dangerous ok
now chief is the only move that it's not
just giving away with the big porn so he
almost has to play it in pre move 94 or
they could capture okay and now I'm just
upon him he had to try that I mean okay
I can actually consider to take take
take f5 and then 95 yeah this is good
it's a good concrete line yeah pushing
this away so that the night will come to
d5 with excellent effect and then f6
Queen h6 and mate on g7 this is the
general idea of this and it should it
should work out if it takes with the
bishop begin 95 this is just too much
stuff hanging Queen at 4 maybe as well
at this is the thing
I mean it's got to be five actually hmm
okay but now Bishop takes a screen g7
made yep there was nothing he couldn't
really defend this anymore that was too
too bad thanks for the game Chakrapani
so this is a bit too long five plus two
yeah
hi do neither three I don't do that so
often on the streams even though it's my
standard move its most standard wings in
over the board chests that have play
most of the time
okay so we have a ready opening
transposing into a Tarrasch
so I'm taking this and now try to get
control over this d4 square and one day
m-maybe that wasn't the most precise
move water yeah not the most precise
move automating again this is a position
that I feel is a bit better for white oh
he allows me to take it it should be
really nice for white better better pawn
structure and the two bishops this is
quite nice so what to do who came I'm
going to control this it's not like I
have the easiest the easiest plans
available this this me
or g4 this actually a good idea why not
try to get a bit of space if I take your
cakes and Eve form this is good yep it
cannot take with the night I'm
threatening this and I'm threatening to
take as somebody mentioned that in the
chain actually okay
yeah I think that was a good spot a good
good thing to spot I think it looks
looks nice non-threatening made by
taking only eight and made hundred seven
yeah thanks for watching she'll-she'll
car I'm that right yeah I can take now
for me
yeah thanks for the game so wysz so
fishy fishy
let's go
order to play oh thank you
so at five over the Kings gambit yeah
okay let's go for that crazy count again
but then always hits two completely
weird positions but always entertaining
and it's not too terrible I think this
is a play of a line at least when I
looked at this long time ago it felt
okay there six he wants to check on age
five hmm but you know if I do this check
kingi seven night f7 Queenie eight he
doesn't do it okay I was fairly sure you
would do do what I said oh why doesn't I
think I can basically trap trap the
bishop okay No
Wow what a weird kind of position can
you force that if it look that looks
somewhat wrong but again I cannot resist
okay so I take this my idea is to trap
this piece trap the noid oh this is a
way to get it back into the game
okay I have a point it's not it's not
like it's completely terrible Oh got a
very active pieces here
if he's sex sex and back I think I'm
fine I definitely find a few plants will
take the three
the thing is king of three the king h3
is the only other move by the ng v g5
defaults actually made them and Bishop
h6 mate okay so what is this what is
this I can play look group f8 King up
and solution and then rook f1
well let's do it
rook F 192 where's the move that
irritates me
I have no time no time it looks like I
should have something but I don't see it
like a mating net or something
ah most of Kings yeah I wanted to go c6
you want some easy moves here I don't
don't see a way 93 would would be made
crazy is going to win on time ok so yeah
good game really fishy fishy
I don't know and I probably spoiled some
good position there but didn't didn't
find it
thanks for the game so well sting no
tango I really need to stop at some
point it's really late now yeah not one
day's what the heck is that
six minutes no who did I decline a
regular challenge ok I think I'm going
to play like 2 more from one or two more
games and then calling it quits it's
close to 2:30 in the morning him so a
lollipop for a team are you going yeah
I'm sorry I think I miss click there i
think i missclicked I wanted to I didn't
want to do that
yeah a lollipop is not playing maybe you
can challenge again
okay let's let's let's let this is going
to be the filing a tingle tangle 10 if
he plays I mean otherwise I'm going to
pick up another challenge so it's going
to be the final game
yeah it's good good in simple
development and it's a little bit tricky
I tried I remember I had a game where
tried night each one edge fire I'm still
going to try that it looks it looks
dangerous maybe this is not objectively
best but it looks dangerous like this
and this 95 now it's almost it is going
to be dangerous 95 I want this I want
the bishop involved this is close close
to working
it is you had the fishing fishing pole I
think it is cold I have no idea why but
it is it is getting it's getting close
this is interesting I don't think he can
take it
let's try and this is the threat it
really is
[Music]
high-five
yeah people know and I should you should
counter this these things in the center
there looks like good good flavor black
he still cannot take it I probably need
Nietzsche so long okay then maybe
canceling long oh you cannot really save
higher rating in fast tempo Falls means
better intuition it's um it's really
it's itself the same yeah tilt angle is
defending this quite well simply refuses
to take any of my my fishy fishy
sacrifice to see ya okay at least I'm
not going to be material down here it's
good
okay and by all this this was Eddie 5
and then Queen to a light square now
what are you doing here
he 5 really I think he's playing this
quite well I still don't get to those
critical squares iam f3 they might be
Queen to you forward
yeah yeah well defended by black hair
care so I have to go here Queenie for I
mean it's not mania and he's taking on
g2 so I will go g3 now this is a this is
a threat serious a serious threat
not getting laid him already resigned
okay thanks for the game t no tengo ten
okay so I'm finishing this stream I've
been on for three and a half hours not
longer than originally intended but it
was very enjoyable thanks a lot for
watching and hanging out with me I will
be on next week for sure at the same
time but there are other things to come
for sure I'm not totally sure about the
schedule because this week I'm going to
have to work a bit on my e4 repertoire
it's almost finished but there's a
little bit the odd things need to do so
I will definitely do something also on
DTS via twitch but we'll see when
exactly that's going to happen thanks a
lot for watching bye bye thank you